[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من موسكو حيث تريدنا
هذه الصور المباشره مع انتهاء اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب اليوم واعلان موسكو رفضه تمديده
وسحب ضماناتها الامنيه لشحنات الحبوب
واغلاق الممر الانسانيه ان واشنطن تحديدا
البيت الابيض نتابع هذه الصور بعد اجراء
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو لمناقشه خطه الاصلاح القضائيه في
اسرائيل ومواضيع اخرى والى مدريد حيث
تردنا هذه الصور المباشره من هناك بعد
اعلان الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه ان البلد
سيسجل درجات حراره عاليه بمستويات غير
طبيعيه بالنسبه لهذا الموسم مشيره الى
انها قد تتجاوز 44 درجه مئويه في مدينه
قرطبه جنوبا وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
الشعب الاب مظاهرات في جنين وغزه تمديدا
باعتقالات السلطه الفلسطينيه في صفوف
المقاومه كتيبه جنين في سرايا القدس تتهم
السلطه بنقد اتفاق تعهدت بموجبه بالافراج
عن معتقليها بعد قبولها بزياره عباس
للجنين متحدث باسم الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه ينفي ان تكون الاعتقالات
سياسيه ومحافظ جنين يقول للجزيره ان
خلفيتها جنائيه وكثائب شهداء الاقصى تتبرا
من الاعتقالات وتدعو ان السلطه الى تصحيح
المسار
معارك داريا في ام درمان ومدن العاصمه
السودانيه الجيش يشن غارات على مواقع
ومعسكرات ومخازن اسلحه للدعم السريع
وحمايه يقول ان اي انتصارات لن تثني قواته
عن قبول خيار الحل السياسي
بعد تعليق مشاركتها في اتفاق حبوب البحر
الاسود موسكو تقول ان السبب هو عدم تلبيه
مطالبها لتعزيز صادراتها من الحبوب
والاسمده كوتيرج يقول ان مئات الملايين في
العالم سيدفعون ثمن القرار الروسي وسط
انتقادات من واشنطن وعواصم اوروبيه
بعد استهداف اوكرانيا جسر القرمه للمره
الثانيه منذ بدء الحرب بوتين يعد بالرد
ويقول ان وزاره الدفاع الروسي تعد
اقتراحات ملائمه وكيف تقول ان الاستخبارات
وسلاح البحريه يقفان وراء تنفيذ الهجوم
على الجسر الاستراتيجي
بعد ختام اجتماعها في الدوحه المجموعه
الخماسيه بشان لبنان تؤكد في بيان لها
مناقشه اتخاذ اجراءات ضد من يعرقل انتخاب
رئيس جديد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
يقول للجزيره ان الدول الخمس تشترك في
التاكيد على سياده لبنان وان حل ازمته
لبناني والخارجيه الامريكيه تقول ان
اجتماع الدوحه اكد الحاجه الماسه للاصلاح
القضائي في لبنان
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تعهد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بين يمين نتنياهو باتخاذ
اجراءات صارمه في مواجهه عدم الامتثال
للخدمه العسكريه من جانب جنود الاحتياط
احتجاجا على خطه التعديلات القضائيه في
غضون ذلك دعا حزب المعسكر الرسمي المعارض
زعيمه بني جانس دعا رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
الى وقف التعديلات القضائيه والكف عما
وصفه بتمزيق المجتمع استطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم ما هي المسارات المحتمله
للازمه في اسرائيل وتصاعدي مظاهر العصيان
داخل الجيش 30 في المئه توقعوا ارتفاع
منسوب التوتر والغضب في الداخل الاسرائيلي
بينما رجح عشرون في المئه تصاعد المواجهه
السياسيه بين نتنياهو والمعارضه اما 50%
فراوا ان هناك امكانيه لابرام تس ويه
داخليه لنزع فتيل الازمه في اسرائيل هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا واستضع صيان
للاوامر العسكريه في اسرائيل نتنياهو يبلغ
بايدن بانه سيحاول بناء توافق واسع في
الراي بشان قانون التعديلات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
كما تابعتم اذا نظم اهالي مخيم جنين
مظاهره تمديدا بالاعتقالات التي تشنها
السلطه الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه وردد
المتظاهرون هتافات تطالب السلطه بالافراج
الفوريه عن المقاومين
الشعب كما شهد قطاع غزه مظاهرات تمديدا
بالاعتقالات التي تقوم بها اجهزه السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه وطالب
المتظاهرون بالافراج الفوري عن المعتقلين
والكف عن ملاحقه المقاومين
محمد صلوات ربي وسلامه عليه
هذا وقالت كتيبه جنينه تابعه لسرايا القدس
انها وافقت على طلب وفد من السلطه زياره
الرئيس الفلسطيني الى جنين مقابل الافراج
عن معتقلين من الكتيبه لدى اجهزه امن
السلطه واضافت ان السلطه واجهزتها الامنيه
نقضت عهدها بالافراج عن مجاهديها بعد
انتهاء زياره عباس الى جنين
وقالت كتائب الشهداء الاقصى مجموعه الرد
السريع كتيبه طولكرم انها تعلن براءتها من
الاعتقالات والملاحقات التي تنفذها السلطه
الفلسطينيه وادعت كتائب الاقصى الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه لتصحيح المسار والكف
عن ملاحقه ابناء الاذرع العسكريه وختمت
كتائب شهداء الاقصى بالقول ان اعانه
الظالم على ظلمه اشد مراره من الظالم نفسه
بحسب ما ورد في نص البيان
في المقابل نفى المتحدث باسم الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه تنفيذ اعتقالات في
الضفه وقال ان الاعتقال الذي طال بعض
الاشخاص جاء بناء على مذكرات قانونيه ومن
جهته قال محافظ جنين ان الاعتقال يتم على
خلفيه جنائيه هي احراق مقر الشرطه
الفلسطينيه في جبع خلال الاجتياح
الاسرائيلي لجنين
معنى من غزه محمد الغول عضو اللجنه
المركزيه للجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد محمد ما هو موقف الجبهه
الشعبيه مما يحدث
نعبر عن ربنا
لسياسه الاعتقال السياسي ونديم بشد
العبارات
استمرار احتجاز
المواطنين على خلفيه الراي وعلى خلفيه
الانتماء السياسي وعلى خلفيه مقاومه
ومقارعه الاحتلال ونؤكد في الجبهه الشعبيه
لتحريف فلسطين ان استمرار هذه السياسه هو
يشكل ربحا صافيا للعدو الصهيوني وللاحتلال
بشكل اساسي ويضرب حاله النسيج المجتمعي
وهي عباره عن صواعق تفجير للعلاقات
الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه لذلك نحذر من
استمرار هذه السياسه وندعو السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى ضروره وقف هذه السياسه
والتراجع عن هذه الاعتقالات واطلاق سراح
كل المعتقلين على خلفيه مقاومه الاحتلال
وعلى خلفيه الانتماء السياسي وايضا ندعو
جماهير شعبنا الى ضروره حمايه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والمقاومين الفلسطينيين من
استمرار هذه السياسه
وايضا دعوتنا الى السلطه الفلسطينيه بان
تعيد حساباتها في كل هذا المسار وان توقف
كل اشكال التنسيق مع الكيان الصهيوني لان
هذا كما تحدثت يشكل ربحا صافيا للعدو
الصهيوني ويضرب الحاله الوطنيه الداخليه
الى اي مدى تهدد برايك هذه الاعتقالات
دعوه الرئيس محمود عباس الى اجتماع
الامناء العامين لفصائل للفصائل
الفلسطينيه
بالتاكيد استمرار الاعتقال السياسي
والسياسه الاعتقال السياسي واستمرار
احتجاز المقاومين تضع حجر وعقبه امام
اللقاء اللقاء المرتقب بنهايه هذا الشهر
ودعوه الرئيس للقاء الامناء العمون هنا
ندعو الى ضروره توفير الاجواء
لانجاح هذا اللقاء المرتقب والذي يعول
عليه شعبنا الفلسطيني ونؤكد بان
يجب ان يتم اطلاق كل المعتقلين السياسيين
تهيئه للاجواء وحتى نذهب ونحن يعني في
اجواء صحيه لهذا اللقاء وان لا يكون هناك
اي اجواء تعكر على صفو هذا اللقاء وتكون
عقبه امام انجاح هذا اللقاء المرتقم كما
وندعو ايضا الى ضروره احترام نتائج هذا
اللقاء المرتقب وايضا ندعو الى ان يكون
هناك
تجريم لسياسه الاعتقال السياسي
وايضا ان يكون احترام لقرارات والنتائج
التي سيخرج عنها هذا اللقاء كما وايضا
ندعو نؤكد بان سياسه الاعتقال السياسي
مرفوضه من الكل الوطني الفلسطيني وعلى
المستوى الشعبي هناك حاله رفض ايضا
لاستمرار هذه السياسه نؤكد بان استمرار
الاعتقال السياسي سيكون عقبه امام يعني اي
لغه حوار اي استماع يعني من شانه ان
يوصلنا الى
المصالحة نعم
بالنسبه لكم في الجبهه الشعبيه كيف تنظرون
الى الاتفاق فيما يخص الجنين بين سلطات
الاحتلال والسلطه الفلسطينيه
يعني نؤكد ان اي اتفاق مع العدو الصهيوني
هو مرفوض يعني لان بالتاكيد العدو
الصهيوني يسعى الى استفاد فكره المقاومه
والى ايضا
محاصره وملاحقه المقاومين والى اعاده
السيطره على جنين واخراجها من معادله
الاشتباك لانه يخبر جيدا ان هذا الوضع لا
يكون لصالح الاحتلال لذلك نؤكد من جديد
انا من حق شعبنا الفلسطيني ان يقاوم
الاحتلال بكل الاشكال وبكل الوسائل وبكل
الطرق لذلك نقوم بشكل
واضح صينيه ومن كل الاطراف
في الداخل الفلسطيني الى حمايه المقاومه
وتعزيز صمود شعبنا الفلسطيني وعدم الردوخ
الاملاءات الامريكيه والصهيونيه التي تهدف
الى تخويض دور المقاومه ويعني
فرض وقائع جديده على الارض لتكون خدمه
شكرا شكرا
من غزه محمد الغول عضو اللجنه المركزيه
للجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
ينضم الينا من غزه سعيد بشارات الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ومن رام الله انور رجب
الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ابدا بك سيد انور كيف
تنظر الى هذه المظاهرات التي كانت تندد
بالاعتقالات اليوم
مساء الخير للاخوه المشاهدين اهلا وسهلا
انما يجري في جنين هو محاوله واضحه وصريحه
لبث الفتنه ونشر الفوضى استجابه لرؤى
وسياسات موجوده لدى بعض القوى بشكل مسبق
وهي تحاول بشكل دؤوبه مستمر
على نشر الفوضى والفلتان في ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه وللاسف تستخدم شعار المقاومه
كمطيه لهذا التوجه
وفيما يتعلق كما اشرت انه هذه هي دعوه
للفتنه وبس الفوضى ولا يمكن القبيل بها
لانه جاءت بصراحه في موعد
يعني يثير الكثير من التساؤلات عمليا
وخاصه بعد الزياره الناجحه للسيد الرئيس
وتاكيد ان اراضي
الضفه الغربيه واعراض دوله فلسطين هي وحده
واحده وانه لا يوجد هناك سلقتين لا في
جنين ولا في غير جنين وان ارسلنا للاحتلال
بان السلطه الفلسطينيه ومن اعلى الهرم
للرئيس الفلسطيني هي زياره الرئيسيه تعبير
عن التلاحم بين السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
والشعب الفلسطيني كما كان دائما
موضوع الاعتقال السياسي
للمعتقلين او تحت بند المقاومه انا اسمح
لي بس اوضح مساله ليس كل من ادعى وحمل صفه
المقاومه فهو مقاوم وليس كل من حمل السلاح
فهو مقاوم تجربتنا كفلسطينيين على مدار
15 او 17 السنه الماضيه اكدت ان كثير من
الكثير يرفعون شعار المقاومه ولهم اهداف
اخرى في غزه
اسمح لي اسمح لي ساعود اليك
لانه لانه يجب ان نوزع الوقت بالعدل ايضا
سيد سعيد وشارات اسمع تعليقا منك
طبعا المظاهرات التي خرجت في جنين هي
استجابه لاجماع فلسطيني عام على ان
الاعتقالات السياسيه المرتبطه بالمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في جنين وفي غير جنين هو امر
مرفوض ومستنكر ولا يخدم سوى الاحتلال
وخاصه في وقت هناك مشاريع استيطانيه
مشاريع احتلاليه تنفذ ضد الفلسطينيين هناك
ضم للضفه الغربيه هناك سيطره على مناطق ما
يسمى سي
بالكامل خططش هناك خطه للاحتلال للتخلص من
الحاله النضاليه من اجل تهيئه الظروف
لتمدد المشروع المشروع الاستيطاني وخاصه
في منطقه شمال الضفه الغربيه حومش ليس
بعيدا عن مخيم جنين وبالتالي مطالب الشعب
الفلسطيني هو حمايه هذه المقاومه في جنين
في نابلس في كل مكان في الضفه الغربيه
ودفع السلطه الى
ان تحدد مسارها تعيد برمجه بوصلتها الى
الاتجاه الوطن الوطني الذي يخدم المقاومه
في الضفه الغربيه ويخدم المشروع الوطني
وينقذ الحاله الفلسطينيه او ما تبقى منها
خلينا نقول في ظل عدم وجود اي افق سياسي
حتى للسلطه الفلسطينيه التي تدافع عن
افعالها في جنين وجمع وفي باقي مناطق
الضفه الغربيه من الاعتقالات السياسيه
المعروفه وكل الشعب الفلسطيني يعلم انها
اعتقالات سياسيه ومن اجل وقت الحاله
الوطنيه التي اتفق عليها في قمه العقبه
ومخرجاتها سيد انور براي كيف ستتعامل
السلطه مع مطالب هذه المظاهرات مع اللفت
النظر الى انه يبدو ان كل فصائل المقاومه
تطالب بالافراج عن المعتقلين الذين تصفهم
بمعتقلين سياسيين بما في ذلك كتائب شهداء
الاقصى
التابعه لحركه فتح
حركه فتح اعلنته بشكل واضح موقفها مما
يجري وليس كل بيان يصدر باسم كتائب الاقصى
هو فعلا صادر باسم كتائب شهداء الاقصى
على اعتقاد السياسي هذه كذبه كبيره ولا
اساس لها من الصحه انا ادعو ضيفيك ليقول
لي كم معتقل سياسي موجود في الضفه الغربيه
لدلالة هذا واحد اثنين كم معتقل على خلفيه
المقاومه موجود في سجون السلطه كما يدعون
هذه كذبه كبيره وهذه محاوله
لاستخدام عناوين وطنيه لبث الفوضى ونشر
الفلاتان في اراضي الضفه الغربيه
المساله الاخرى ان كما اصرت ليس كل من
يحمل صفه المقاومه فهو مقاوم الاعتقالات
التي تمت هي تمت بشكل قانوني وعلى خلفيه
جنائيه غير مسموح لاي كان ان يهاجم مقرات
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وتحت اي كانت
لم يسمح
بنشر الفوضى والفلتان والاجهزه الامنيه
ستصل لكل من يحاول ان يعتدي على هذه
المؤسسات ويبث الفوضى هذه محاوله لنشر
الفوضى والفتن انا دعني اقول لك شيئا
واحدا الاسماء التي تروج
كانه معتقلين سياسيين هؤلاء يروج لقائمه
بخمسه وخمسين اسم هل تعلم ان اكثر من عشره
منهم او يزيد عن ذلك تم الافراج عنهم منذ
2016 و 2019 و2021 و2022 اذا هذه كذبه
سمجه بمحاوله توتير الاوضاع في الضفه
الغربيه وافشال
الدعوه دعوه التي دعا لها السيد الرئيس
والسلطه الوطنيه ليست بحاجه لان تعود
بوصلتها باتجاه الوطن
ما هي السياقات التي دفعت الى الضغط على
هذا النحو في هذا التوقيت على السلطه
الفلسطينيه
السياقات التي تاتي فيها كل هذه الاحداث
هي
قمه العقبه التي خرجت بمخرجات يتم تنفيذها
للاسف جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قام بعمليه
في جنين في ظل ان السلطه كانت غير قادره
على فرض سلطتها كما يسمونها في تلك الفتره
هيات لها الجو دخلت مخيم جنين وهيات ايضا
الاداره الامريكيه واسرائيل ومعها الاردن
لوصول محمود عباس ابو مازن رئيس السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى جنين وبالتالي كل هذه
التشكيله التي تسمعها مني هي تخدم ما يريد
الاحتلال الاحتلال صراحه يقول نحن نتعامل
مع السلطه كجهه نريد ان تفرض الامن في
منطقه شمال الضفه والا سندخل نحن ونفرض
الامن السلطه الفلسطينيه الان تقوم بهذا
الدور للاسف جاءت بهذه الحمله او العمليه
عمليه الاعتقالات والمطاردات للمقاومين
الذين يقاومنون الاحتلال ولا يسعون الى
اثاره الفتنه
بطلب من الاحتلال لفرض حاله امنيه يريدها
الاحتلال الاحتلال يهدد السلطه وبصراحه
السلطه التزمت بما يريد الاحتلال بمساعده
اردنيه بضغط من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كل هذا الاحداث اتت بشكل متسارع
يعني اجتياح جنين فدخول فتنفيذ الاعتقالات
يعني لا تريد مزيد من الشرح الامور من غزه
سعيد بشارات الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
رام الله انور رجب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
وجه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن دعوه لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
لزياره واشنطن وذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي
تطرقا خلال خطه الاصلاح القضائي المثيره
للجدل في اسرائيل وعلى ضوء الاحتجاجات
المتصاعده على تلك التعديلات حضره بنيامين
نتنياهو من مغبه تمنع الجنود عن الخدمه
اعتراضا على خطته الاصلاحيه وقال ان ذلك
عصيان للاوامر العسكريه ويهدد امن اسرائيل
في المقابل قال زعيم المعارضه ان الحكومه
تقود الشعب الى كارثه قوميه وترفض الاقرار
بذلك
الرفض متسلحا بالاصرار
تتسع دائره احتجاجات اسرائيل على قانون
التعديلات القضائيه
هكذا تساعد المعارضه حملتها المستمره منذ
نصف عام مع سعي الائتلاف الحكومي لتصديق
على التعديل الرئيسي قبل بدايه عطله
الكنيست الصيفيه يقول زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه الى الحكومه تقود اسرائيل نحو
كارثه ويطالبها بالتوقف عن التشريعات
والتوصل الى تسويه
يرى بان اجراءات الحكومه الراميه الى
احداث تغييرات في الجهاز القضائي معاديه
للديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيات اما عندنا التحريض على عصيان
الاوامر العسكريه وعصيانها يمس مباشره
بامن مواطني اسرائيل ويقدم من قوه ردينا
امام اعدائنا الذين قد يغريهم الامر
لمهاجمتنا ما قد يبدو لنتنياهو اشبه
بمحاوله انقلابيه يراه خطرا على
ديموقراطيه اسرائيل وامنها لذلك تجده يذكر
بضروره خضوع الجيش لقياده الحكومه
المنتخبه ديمقراطيا كما يقول ما زال وزير
الدفاع يبحث الموقف وتداعياته المحتمله مع
كبار المسؤولين العسكريين في تل ابيب تثار
هنا تساؤلات عما قد تجره الاحتجاجات
المتصاعده على خطه الاصلاحات القضائيه من
تاثيرات على كفاءه جيش الاحتلال لكن على
المستوى السياسي ثم قلق بشان تماسك الجبهه
الداخليه اذا اقر الائتلاف الحكومي
تشريعاته القضائيه تزايد الاحتجاجات
المناه ضه لتلك التشريعات له كما يبدو صدا
في واشنطن في اول اتصال هاتفي بينهما منذ
شهور بحث الرئيس الامريكي لمساله وقضايا
اخرى مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في
الاتصال نفسه بايدن دعا لتنياهو اخيرا
لزياره البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم بان
الطائرات الحربيه قصفت اليوم تجمعات لقوات
الدعم السريع في مناطق حمد النيل وعد
البشير وسط مدينه ام درمان وجنوبها كما
نفذت المسيرات التابعه للجيش ضربات على
تجمعات للدعم السريع في منطقه الجريف
الشرق في العاصمه السودانيه وشملت الضربات
معسكر خوله التابعه للدعم السريع في
الخرطوم من جهتها قالت مصادر ومحليه
للجزيره ان طائرات الحربيه قصفت منطقه حله
حمد المتاخمه للقصر الرئاسي في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري ودمرت اسلحه تابعه للدعم
السريع بينما ذكرت مصادر عسكريه تابعه
للجيش للجزيره ان القوات المسلحه استعادت
السيطره على حاميه دلوكه جنوب غرب مدينه
كادوقلي عاصمه ولايه جنوب كردفان بعد
معارك مع قوات الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان شمال
بزعامه عبد العزيز الحلو
في الاثناء قال رئيس قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو ان الحرب التي تجاوزت
ثلاثه اشهر ضاعفت من معاناه السودانيين
لاسيما في الخرطوم ودارفوره واضاف دالو في
رساله صوتيه نشرها على حسابه في تويتر انه
رغم الانتصارات التي تحققها قواته قواته
فانه جاهز لقبول خيار الحل السياسي
ننتظرين اي انتصارات مهما عظمه من ان
نتقدم بشجاعه بقبول خيال الحل السياسي
الشامل لمعالجه جذور الازمه السودانيه
التاريخيه فالحرب ليست غايه
ان سواعد الاشاره التي تمسك البندقيه قادر
على حمل اغصان الزيتون ليتحمل الشرفاء في
القوات المسلحه المسؤوليه وانحاز الخيار
الشعب فالمهم عندنا الانتصار لاراده شعبنا
لثورته المجيده وليس الحظوظ النفس
وهذه صور جاءت قبل قليل لرئيس مجلس
السياده الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان خلال
اجتماع
للقياده العامه
هذا يتزامن اذا مع
التسجيل المنسوب لمحمد حمدان دقلو الذي
بثته الجزيره ايضا وكما سمعتم قال انه
مستعد لحل سياسي ايضا
وهو يريد مصلحه الشعب السوداني وليس حظوظ
النفس كما قال في هذه الاثناء
يحرص سيدنا الرئيس مجلس السياده ايضا
بدوره على
الظهور وكما ذكرت هذا الظهور هو في اجتماع
لمجلس القياده
او القياده العامه انضم الينا هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني نبدا من ظهور
البرهان بالتاكيد قبل دقائق من الان
انطلقت اشاعه مفردها ان قوات الدعم السريع
القت القبضه على البرهان وشهدت العاصمه
القرطوم احتفالات صاخبه باطلاق النار
لمقاتليه دعم السريع في الهواء فرحا بذلك
الخبر بصوره عامه اتضح انه مجرد اشاعه وان
على سبيل لا صحه له واعقب ذلك ظهور هذه
الفيديو
للفريق اول عبد الفتاح الفيديو ده اين في
مبنى القياده العامه مكان وجود البرهان
معلوم للكافه ومعلن هو نفسه ذكر قبل ذلك
انه موجود مع مقاتله
في القياده العامه وانه يقود غرفه
العمليات بنفسه طبعا الاشاعات لا تطاله هو
فقط ولكن تطال حمايه ايضا قائد القوات
الدعم السريع مات ما مات اصيب ذكاء
اصطناعي دائما حديث هذا النوع ولكن على كل
حال في التسجيل المنسوب اليه سمعت كيف انه
يعني يقول انه مستعد لخيار ايضا غصن
الزيتون وليس حمل السلاح فقط نعم كما ذكرت
انت فان التسجيلات الصوتيه المتتاليه
واختفاء عن المشهد وكفو عن اجراء حوارات
تلفزيونيه وهو مشهور بوضع شديد بالظهور
وبالحديث حتى في ايام السجن ويتحدث كثيرا
ويخرج للعلن كثيرا ويخاطب كل لقاء لذلك
اسار اكتفاء بتسجيلات صوتيه جدلا واسعا
حول حقيقه وضع الصحي صيامه مثل هذه
الرسائل الصوتيه تناشت من منذ وقت طويل
وارتبطت بشخصيات
مطارده او شخصيات يعني هذا قد يثير المزيد
من الشائعات حوله ولكن عندما كان يمكن ان
تعلق حول مضمون ما جاء فيه وتزامن هذا
ايضا مع اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
دارفور من قبل الامم المتحده
كيف تنظر الى الرد او هل كان هناك رد على
هذه النقطه بالتحديد هذه الاتهامات يبدو
انها صارت قلق كل قاعده الدعم السريع
الاتهامات والادانات تعددت من كل المؤسسات
الدوليه على مختلف مستوياتها مؤسسات
المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان عام
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه وعدد من هذا الرد
على ذلك بكل تاكيد جانب من هذا التسجيل
تطرق لتلك
الجزئيات وحو اعتذارا للشعب السوداني عن
معاناه معاناه التي تسببت فيها الحرب ولكن
الجديد في هذا الخطاب حديث حماتي عن تكوين
جيش جديد خلافا لما ظل يتردد في الفتره
الماضيه عن اعاده هيكله الجيش واصلاحه
ودمج كل القوات فيه لتكوين جيش مهني واحد
اليوم المشهد حديثا جديدا عن تفكيك الجيش
الحالي على اعتبار انه مرتبط عندهم بتنظيم
اسلاميه بعينه وهذا خطاب جديد وليس معهود
في كيف تفهم
الخطاب الاعلامي لقوات الدعم السريعه لا
يتغير ويتحور من فتره لاخرى مع بدايه
الحرب كان الخطاب موجها
وعود بتحقيق شعارات ثوره ابريل الحريه
والسلام والعداله والقضاء على
التيار الاسلامي في الجيش
ومحاربه الانقلابيين ثم تحول للحديث عن
القضاء على دوله 56 الان مشهد حديثا جديدا
عن
حل الجيش الحالي وتكوين جيش جديد هو خطاب
مضطرب ومتحور
وبلايز على حل شكرا جزيلا الدكتور مزمل
ابو القاسم الكاتب المحلل السياسي
السوداني شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اعلن الكرملين ان اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود قد انتهت بالنسبه لروسيا
واوضح ان موسكو ستعود على الفور الى
الاتفاقيه بمجرد تلبيه مطالبها وبينما
يخيم شبح ازمه الغذاء خصوصا القمح والذره
على ملايين المحتاجين لتلك الحبوب في
انحاء العالم تظهر اهميه اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب لاسيه وقد تحدثت وكاله بلومبرغ عن
ارتفاع قيمه العقود الاجله للقمح والذره
تعلن روسيا اعتراضها على استمرار
الاتفاقيه التي تسمح بتصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود لكنها تترك الباب مفتوحا
امام استئناف العمل بها قال المتحدث باسم
الكريم
انه بمجرد تنفيذ الجزء المتعلق بروسيا من
الاتفاقيه ستعود اليها فورا الرئيس التركي
الذي اثمرت وساطته الاتفاقيه بدا متفائلا
ايضا وقال انه رغم اعلان توقف الاتفاقيه
فان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين يريد الاستمرار
فيها بدا العمل باتفاقيه الحبوب في يوليو
السنه الماضيه بواسطه تركيه ورعايه امميه
تؤمن الاتفاق السفن التي تنقل الحبوب في
البحر الاسود عبر مضيق البوسفور في اتجاه
مناطق مختلفه من العالم تقدم روسيا ضمانات
امنيه يسمح من خلالها اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي بفتح ممر بحري انساني ويضمن سلامه
الملاحه البحريه وهي الضمانات التي اعلنت
روسيا سحبها الان في اسطنبول اقيم مركز
للمراقبه لتفتيش السفن من عدم استغلالها
لنقل الاسلحه تشارك فيه روسيا واوكرانيا
وتركيا والامم المتحده لماذا هذه
الاتفاقيه مهمه تنتج روسيا واوكرانيا نحو
ثلث ما يحتاج اليه العالم من الحبوب ولذلك
شهدت اسعارها بعد اندلاع حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ارتطاعا صاروخيا عاد تطبيق
الاتفاقيه بعد التوازن الى السوق العالميه
وتمكنت اوكرانيا خلال سنه تقريبا من تصدير
نحو 33 مليون طن من الحبوب لكن روسيا
انسحبت منها ثلاث مرات في السابق قبل ان
تعود اليها في كل مره بعد وقت قصير تقول
موسكو ان البنود المتعلقه بتصدير حبوبها
واسمنتها لا تحترم وتضيف ان اغلب حبوب
اوكرانيا توجه الى الدول الغنيه ولا
تستفيد منها الدول الفقيره لا تخضع المواد
الغذائيه الروسيه للعقوبات الغربيه لكن
شركات النقل والتامين تتردد في نقل هذه
المواد خوفا من التي تفرضها العقوبات على
التحويلات الماليه ومع ذلك تمكنت روسيا
حسب اداره التقريرات الفلاحيه الامريكيه
من تصدير خمسه واربعين مليون وخمسمائه الف
طن من الحبوب في عام 2022 وتتوقع ان تصدر
اكثر هذه السنه الان يقول الرئيس
الاوكراني
ان بلاده مستعده لتصدير الحبوب حتى دون
مشاركه روسيا اذا تلقت ضمانات من الشركاء
لكن الجميع يامل عوده روسيه سريعه الى
الاتفاقيه لان اسعار القمح في سوق شيكاغو
ارتفعت بنسبه 3% مباشره بعد اعلان توقف
العمل بالاتفاقيه
معنا من موسكو
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الابحاث
الوطنيه وامبراتيزلافا الينا كوتسكو نائبه
رئيس معهد
ومديره معهد سياسات الامن العالميه اهلا
وسهلا بكما ابدا بك سيده اولغا
يعني هذا القرار للرئيس بوتين لماذا يعني
اتخذه هو ما الاهداف الاستراتيجيه له
الاستراتيجيه له
نحن نتحدث عن قرار مفهوم من جانب الاتحاد
الروسي والرئيس الروسي لان الالتزامات
التي تقدمت بها الدول الغربيه بالنسبه الى
اتفاقيه الحبوب لم تلتزم او لم تحترم في
حقيقه الامر ان روسيا قدمت الضمانات
الامنيه واحترمت ما تعاهدت به في اتفاقيه
الحبوب ولكن في المقابل الدول الاخرى لم
تحترم هذه البنود المختلفه وخصوصا بالنسبه
الى الصادرات
الروسيه من حبوب ومن اسمده على وجه الخصوص
ان روسيا لم يسمح لها ببيع هذه المنتجات
ولذلك روسيا نرى انها احترمت ما تعهدت به
ولكن البلدان الاخرى لم تقم بذلك وبالتالي
من غير المجدي بالنسبه الى روسيا
الاستمرار بهذه الاتفاقيه سيد الين ما
رايك الا يعتبر بهذه الطريقه اذا موقف
روسيا مبررا كما تقول السيده اولجا بما ان
الاطراف الاخرى لم تلتزم بما تعهدت به اذا
اذا روسيا
في حقيقه الامر السيد الضيف كراريس لم
تقدم الصوره الواضحه ان الاطراف جميعا
تحترم هذه
بنود المختلفه ما من عقوبات فرضت على
الحبوب الروسيه وعلى
الاسمده الروسيا للتاكد من عدم وجود
العراقيل الماليه الاتحاد الاوروبي قدم
ضمانات اضافيه على سبيل المثال استحداث
اليات على مستوى البنوك الاوروبيه تتعامل
مع هذه التبادلات التجاريه الصادره من
روسيا ولكن روسيا رفضت هذه العروض وهذا ما
يشير الى نيه روسيا
بالانسحاب من الاتفاق وان روسيا ايضا
يمكنها ان ترى انه ما من اسلحه كما سبق
وقال ت في الماضي وذلك برعايه من الامم
المتحده وتركيا وبالتالي ما من خروق لهذه
السيده اولغا قد تستفيد روسيا ربما للضغط
على الجانب الاوكراني ولكن ما فائده الدول
الاخرى في ان لا تلتزم وتتسبب في ازمه
عالميه
سنه الماضيه اوكرانيا كانت تقوم بالاعمال
التجاريه كالمعتاد وتبيع الحبوب وتصدر
الحبوب والبلدان التي هي بحاجه الى هذه
الحبوب بحقيقه الامر لا اعتقد انها حصلت
على تلك الحبوب هذه الحبوب فقط صدرت
لفائده الدول الغربيه وهو عكس ما تم
الاتفاق عليه ولذلك روسيا ليس من مصلحتها
ان تقدم الضمانات الامنيه كي تتمكن
اوكرانيا من القيام بالعمليات التجاريه
وتصدير حبوبها ليس للدول التي هي بحاجه
اليها بل كاعمال تجاريه طبيعيه فاذا الينا
الى اي مدى تعتقدين ان قراراتك هذه
وخلافات كهذه تتعلق
بالمعارك على الارض وهل
هناك دلاله لتزامن هذا القرار مع استهداف
جسر القرن
تغيير في المعطيات المرتبطه
باتفاق الحبوب من جانب اوكرانيا كانت
روسيا تلتزم لاشهر وبعد اشهر تهدد
بالانسحاب من الاتفاق من جانب تركيا من
جانب الامم المتحده من جانب اوكرانيا ما
من شروطا ما من تغيير في السلوك في البحر
الاسود كي تغير روسيا في موقفها ولذلك هذا
يؤشر الى ان المشكله في مكان اخر طبعا
روسيا قالت ان هذا الامر لا يرتبط بشكل
مباشر بتفجير جسر القرم ولكن ما يمكن ان
نقوله هو ان روسيا لا تحقق النجاحات في
اوكرانيا لا تبلي بلاء حسنا في الميدان
وتعاني بسبب العقوبات المفروطه على القطاع
العسكري الروسي ولذلك روسيا تود ان تتاكد
من الحفاظ على ضخ الاموال من مصادر مختلفه
الاقتصادها ولتمويل جهود الحرب والاعتداء
على اوكرانيا
هل يمكن ان نشهد عوده روسيه قريبه لهذا
الاتفاق ووفق اي شروط
انه من الواضح وكما قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين انه عندما تؤخذ المصالح
الروسيه بعين الاعتبار سوف تعود روسيا الى
اتفاق الحبوب وبكل تاكيد لا يمكن ان يلقى
اللوم على روسيا اذا ازاء هذه التبعات
عندما تؤخذ المصالح الروسيه بعين الاعتبار
وشروط التي اعلن عنها في العام الماضي
عندما تحترم روسيا تعود الى اتفاق الحبوب
وتقدم الضمانات الامنيه كما تم الاتفاق
عليه لايصال هذه الحبوب للدول التي هي
بحاجه اليها ولكن بالنظر الى المعطيات
الحاليه ليس في مصلحه روسيا ان تبقى في
هذا الاتفاق وذكرتم
تفجير لضيق الوقت دعني اسال عن هذه الن
قطه باختصار شديد السيده اليناء لماذا
تركز اوكرانيا
يعني على جسر القرن مرارا وتكرارا
[موسيقى]
من غير الواضح
والاتحاد الروسي طبعا يوجه الاتهامات
واوكرانيا تبلي بلاء افضل في مجال المعارك
الميدانيه للسيطره على الاراضي التي
خسرتها في السابق ومن الواضح ان روسيا
تحاول ان تقوم بالرد لتتاكد من الضغط على
اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لكم من
نائبه رئيس معهد جلوب ساك ومديره معهد
سياسات الامن العالمي ومن موسكو اولغا
كراسي نياك استاذه العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه الابحاث الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه لحصاد الليله نخصصها لموضوع
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الذي كنا نتحدث عنه
والذي اعلنت روسيا الانسحاب منه فما هو
ذلك الاتفاق وما اهميته للغذاء العالمي
ولماذا اثار القرار الروسي كل هذه الضجه
وردود الفعل الغاضب الاتفاق الملغي تم
توقيعه في اسطنبول شهر تموز من العام
الماضي بين روسيا وتركيا واوكرانيا والامم
المتحده لاستئناف نقل صادرات الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه عبر ممر الانساني في
البحر الاسود تنطلق السفن من ثلاثه موانئ
اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود وهي موانئني
كما تشاهدون هنا ويتم تفتيش السفن قبل
انطلاقها من اوكرانيا من قبل ممثلين
اوكرانيين واتراك وامميين تسلك السفن
ممرات امنه عبر البحر الاسود وتتم
متابعتها لضمان عدم تعرضها لاي ويعمل مركز
المراقبه في اسطنبول على مراقبه تلك السفن
بالتنسيق مع الدول المعنيه والامم المتحده
عند وصول السفن لمضيق البوسفور التركيه
يتم توزيعها على الموانئ التركيه وتخضع
لعمليه تفتيش جديده قبل ان تستانف رحلتها
الى وجهتها النهائيه في طريق عودتها فارغه
تخضع السفن للتفتيش مره اخرى في الموانئ
التركيه للتاكد من عدم حملها اسلحه قبل ان
تسلك الممرات الامنه عائده الى اوكرانيا
اما اخر سفينه شحن وافقت عليها الاطراف
الاتفاق فكانت في وقت متاخر امس الاحد عبر
البحر الاسود من ميناء اوديسا الاوكراني
الى اسطنبول من اسطنبول التركي اتفاقيه
الحبوب التي استمرت نحو عام كان لها اثر
ايجابي على توفر الغذاء وكبح اسعاره على
مستوى العالم فمنذ تحرك اول سفينه في
الاول من اغسطس الم سمح الاتفاق بشحن نحو
33 مليون طن من الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه
الاخرى الى العالم عبر اكثر من الف سفينه
ووفق احصائيات تركيه تم نقل اربعين في
المئه من الحبوب المشحونه الى اوروبا و30%
نحو اسيا و13% الى تركيا واثني عشر في
المئه نحو افريقيا وخمسه في المئه الى
الشرق الاوسط كما اتاح الاتفاق لبرامج
الاغذيه العالمي مساعده العالميه برنامج
الغذاء العالمي مساعده بلدان تواجه نقصا
غذائيا حادا مثل افغانستان والسودان
واليمن وتقديم معونات في ملايين اللاجئين
في عده مناطق تنضم الينا من برلين صوفيا
مونسالفيا الامينو العام لمنظمه فيان
الدوليه لحقوق الغذاء اهلا وسهلا بك هذا
الانسحاب الروسي من الاتفاق الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يتسبب في كارثه
غذائيه في العالم
نعم بكل تاكيدا هذا الانسحاب الروسي هو
بالخبر السيء للملايين من الناس الذين
يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي في العالم
وهذه انباء غير جيده بالنسبه الى البلدان
التي تعتمد على المساعدات من برنامج
الغذاء العالمي اثيوبيا اليمن وافغانستان
على سبيل المثال وبالتالي سوف نشهد
ارتفاعا لاسعار الغذاء خصوصا بعد استفاده
المضاربين من هذا الوضع وهذا هو الخوف
الاساسي ان هذه
الاتفاقيه كما اشرتم ساعدت في كبح ارتفاع
الاسعار وبالتالي ما هي الحلول
المتاحه ما هي البدائل
الوضع
دقيق للغايه طبعا يجب الاستمرار بالعمل في
هذه الاتفاقيه وهذا يساعد ولكن الاهم هو
ان هذا الحل هو الحل الاكثر هشاشه لذلك من
الاهميه بمكان على مستوى الامم المتحده
العمل على مساعده الاكتفاء الغذائي في عدد
كبير من البلدان لطالما استمعنا الى
الخطابات التي تسلط الضوء على اهميه
التجاره الدوليه ولكن اما ان نراه هو ان
عددا كبيرا من البلدان غير قادر على
انتاجي الغذاء على المستوى المحلي لتحقيق
الاكتفاء الذاتي الاكتفاء الذاتي هو
النقطه الاهم العمل على ذلك هذا اولا
ثانيا عبء الديون عدد كبير من هذه البلدان
يعاني من ديون لذلك يجب العمل على تخفيف
عبء الديون لهذه البلدان سوف هي مونسالفي
الامين العام لمنظمه فيان الدوليه لحقوق
الانسان حدثتنا من برلين شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وصفت روسيا استهداف جسر القرم
بزورقين مسيرين بالعمل الارهابي وقاره
وزاره الخارجيه ان المتورطين سيقدمون الى
العداله وكانت كيف قد اعلنت في وقت سابق
ان وحدات من القوات البحريه وجهاز الامن
تمكنت من استهداف الجسر تاركه اعلان ما
سمته تفاصيله تنظيم التفجير لما بعد
الانتصار على روسيا حسب تعبير امن الدوله
الاوكرانيه التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
يربط شبه جزيره القرم بالاراضي الروسيه
ويمتد الى اقليم كرسنو دار جنوب غربي
روسيا انشات موسكو عام 2018
ويؤدي دورا استراتيجيا بالنسبه لروسيا في
نقل البضائع والسلع وحتى امدادات المياه
العذبه والطاقه الكهربائيه وبالطبع
الامدادات العسكريه
عملت روسيا على تحصينه بنشر منظومات دفاع
جوي وقطع عسكريه قرب مضيق كرش اضافه الى
كاميرات مراقبه
الخارجيه الروسيه وصفت الهجوم بالارهابي
واكدت العمل على تحديد المسؤوليه ونتيجه
للاستهداف الغت مقاطعه
الليلي للسماح بعبور السيارات من مقاطعه
روستوف الروسيه باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم
عبر ماريو بول باتجاه مقااطعتي
وصولا الى القرد ووصل هذه التطورات صدرت
دعوات لضم مزيد من المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
بل اكثر من ذلك فالدعوات وصلت الى حد منع
اوكرانيا من اي منفذ على البحر الاسود
وكان الجسر استراتيجي قد تعرض لهجوم
بشاحنه ملغمه في اكتوبر الماضي اصابته
باضرار وتله قصف جوي روسي مكثف استهدف
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
قال بيان صادر عن المجموعه الخماسيه بشان
لبنان المنعقد في الدوحه انه جرى نقاش
اتخاذ اجراءات ضد من يعرقل انتخاب رئيس
جديد للبلاد واكد البيان استعداد الدول
الخمس وهي مصر وفرنسا وقطر والسعوديه
والولايات المتحده لدعم تنفيذ اصلاحات
اقتصاديه يوصي بها صندوق النقد الدولي كما
اشار بيان المجموعه الخماسيه الى ان على
اعضاء البرلمان اللبناني الالتزام
بمسؤوليتهم والشروع في انتخاب رئيس للبلاد
وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه ماجد
الانصاري ان بيان المجموعه الخماسيه اكد
ان الحل في لبنان يجب ان يكون لبنانيا
موضحا ان بيان الدول الخمس عبر عن قلق
بالغ بشان الفراغ الدستوريه في لبنان الذي
استمر تسعه اشهر
ان المساله المهمه هنا ان هذا البيان يدعو
الى ان يكون الحل لبنانيا وان يكون
التوافق لبنانيا وان هذا هو ما يجب ان
يقوم به مجتمع الدولي هو الدفع لتوافق في
في لبنان وليس املاء الاملاء على
اللبنانيين كيف يحلون هذه الازمه
وقال الانصاري ان اجتماع المجموعه
الخماسيه بشان لبنان اكد الالتزام بدعم
سياده لبنان واستقلالها
حقيقه ان البيان لم يحدد هذه الاجراءات
ولكن اعتقد ان واضح بالنسبه
للجمهور العام كيف يمكن للمجتمع الدولي ان
يمارس الضغط في هذا الاطار خاصه ان هذه
الدول الخمسه تتمتع بعلاقات وبتاثير
اقتصادي وسياسي كبير جدا على الشان
اللبناني وهناك الكثير من اليات الضغط
التي يمكن استخدامها في سبيل تحقيق
التوافق في لبنان
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيوم ان المجموعه الخماسيه
التي تضم الى جانب بلاده السعوديه ومصر
وقطر وفرنسا شددت خلال اجتماع لها في
العاصمه القطريه على التزامها بدعم سياده
لبنان واستقلاله
الدول الخمس اكدت التزامها بالسياده لبنان
واستقلاله لكننا لاحظنا بقلق عدم انتخاب
القاده السياسيين لرئيس جديد بعد نحو تسعه
اشهر من انتهاء ولايه الرئيس اكدت الدول
على الحاجه الملحه الى لاصلاح القضائي
وتطبيق القانون لا سيما فيما يتعلق
بالتحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت عام 2020
[موسيقى]
نختم جولتنا بمشهد مثير للانتباه فمن
ناحيه تخطت درجات الحراره مستويات قياسيه
في بعض انحاء النصف الشمالي من الكره
الارضيه اليوم الامر الذي تسبب في حرائق
قرابات في تجنب جديد لتظاهر لظاهره التغير
المناخي اصدرت دول في اوروبا واسيا
وامريكا الشماليه تحذيرات صحيه واجرت
عمليات اجلاء للسكان وفي الوقت ذاته تسببت
سلسله من السيول والفيضانات والانهيارات
الارضيه في سقوط قتلى ومصابين ومفقودين في
عدد من دول العالم بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه
يصعب ان يعزى حدث مناخي معين للتغير
المناخي لكن العديد من العلماء يشددون على
ان الاحترار العالمي كما يوصف والمرتبط
بالاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري هو السبب
في موجات الحر الشديد كما يكثر حدوث
الفيضانات وانهيارات التربه خلال الامطار
الموسميه لكن الخبراء يقولون ان التغير
المناخيه يزيد من تفاقمها وشدتها شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]